a powerful category 4 hurricane is
closing in on Hawaii this morning right
now hurricane lane is 180 miles from
Hawaii's Big Island and packing winds of
145 miles an hour
a storm is expected to get dangerously
close to the Big Island and Maui later
today
Matea Vol is on Maui where the wind and
rain are starting to pick up but I a
good morning well good morning there is
a state of emergency here at on Hawaii's
Big Island we also know as of right now
all of the public schools have been
cancelled through the rest of the week
Honolulu has 150 FEMA emergency
responders ready to go at a moment's
notice but across Hawaii it has been a
race against this storm we do not want
to see what happened in Puerto Rico and
we do that by making sure we're prepared
Honolulu mayor Kirk Caldwell warned
Hawaiians Wednesday to take hurricane
Laine seriously it threatens to bring
catastrophic flooding monsterous surf
and powerful winds we've been preparing
for this we'll be ready for this and
we'll be working on the recovery
response mode should the worst occur
satellite images taken from space show
the massive storm churning in the
Pacific Ocean government scientists
Wednesday released this video as they
flew into the eye of the hurricane I
think it's gonna be bad to an effect
that us locals never experienced before
people on the islands rushed to get
supplies filling up grocery carts and
emptying store shelves several
businesses also placed sandbags in an
effort to prevent flooding it's been a
summer of destruction on Hawaii's Big
Island where the Kilauea volcano
destroyed more than 700 homes since May
up to 2 feet of rain could now hit that
same region and potentially deadly
flooding and mudslides are a major
concern
the only hurricane to make landfall in
state recorded history is Hurricane
Iniki a category 4 storm back in
September 1992 seven people died and
there was more than a billion dollars in
damage Maui's mayor said they haven't
faced a hurricane of lanes magnitude
before this is the most serious
potential that I've seen
and I've been alive 63 years in the last
24 hours I have personally seen a lot of
a wind and rain picking up in this area
the US Navy has moved their ships and
submarines out to sea and away from the
storm's path this is the second major
storm to threaten the Hawaiian Islands
in the last two weeks and hurricane Lane
is already closer and more powerful than
the last storm which was hurricane
Hector bianna and you hear the mayor say
they want to avoid another Puerto Rico
really telling their Maria be Ariel
thank you